salut aujourd'hui je vais vous parler
d'un smartphone qui est arrivé il n'y a
pas longtemps c'est le poke au f4
j'étais je crois qu'en france et le
smartphone de poko le plus cher qui soit
jamais sorti poko est une sous marque de
xiaoming fait partie de la famille de
siouville même s'ils sont vraiment en
train de laisser pareille s'est déjà
séparé au niveau international il
travaille comme une marque à part
entière en france c'était xiaomi qui
était derrière ces deux heures toujours
shiomi qui est derrière mais au lieu de
le retrouver sur le site de chiots mais
vous avez un site dédié poko pour venir
trouver ce produit est celui là il est
intéressant pourquoi parce que ils ont
fait un gros travail au niveau du
smartphone en lui-même rajouter des
boutons rajouter des possibilités pour
une fois de plus à l'est dans l'idée du
gaming et de draguer les gamer donc on
va regarder si ce pot coeff iv gt qui
coûte quand même je voulais tout de
suite vous avez deux conflits qu'une
version 8 plus 128 5 199 90 et une
version 12 plus de 250 6 699 euros 90
donc on est quasiment 700 balle dans la
plus grosse configuration entre 600 et
700 euros est ce que ça vaut le coup de
venir acheter ce smartphone là ou alors
est-ce que c'est pas du tout la bonne
solution c'est ce qu'on va me regarder
une femme avenante
regardez ce smartphone il est là il est
ouvert il est il est là il est là alors
le premier truc ça ça va être compliqué
pour vous en rendre compte mais moi je
vous dis tout de suite ça sera un truc
que je trouve lourd on a une petite
brique dans la main alors mets des
guillemets quand je dis ça c'est pas
réellement une brique mais fait quand
même ses 210 g et croyez-moi on sent
réellement alors smartphones de gaming
on va sans doute et qui aura des
composants qui vont peser un peu l'eau
méchant que la batterie si elle fait
4700 milliampères heures laissez-moi
vérifier l'histoire c'est ça 4700
millions terreur il a un truc qui est
super intéressante aux smartphones c'est
ce que poko est venu nous mettre juste
sur le dessus ici c'est à dire que la
regarde et il est pas fait comme
n'importe quel smartphone ça qui est
intéressant on va retrouver ici des
espèces de petites rigueur vous voyez
des petits boutons là ici on aime
glissière ici j'ai un bouton ici c'est
pareil j'ai une glissière ici j'ai le
trigger alors qu'est ce que ça sera
comme ça en fait ça s'est fait pour le
gaming est alors si on regarde de
l'autre côté c'est là ça devient encore
plus fine qui est tombée presque vous
avez ici vos boutons de volume r d ont
aussi deux ou les zooms et zoomer et
climatiques mike pour micro pourquoi
parce que en fait ils nous ont mis trois
micros à l'extérieur ce smartphone pour
lorsque vous allez être dans des party
gaming pouvoir converser facilement
échanger une fois de plus c'est l'adn de
poko celle gaming et il le montre
davantage ici alors ce qu'il faut
vraiment retenir ici c'est qu'ici la ce
que vous avez c'est effectivement des
petites rigueur pour venir jouer avec
votre manette vous appuyez ça vous fait
des petits boutons donc à ça vous fait
un bouton là un bouton là et ça ça sert
à venir louvre y regarder il est comme
ça il est fermé je tire le bouton sort
vous voyez là il sort tac alors je
trouve ça mal hein mais en fait par
rapport à ce que j'ai déjà vu ailleurs
pour que ça sert un peu à rien parce que
vous avez des marques qui font un truc
assez malin ou en fait vous avez juste
une petite zone tactile vous touchez et
pas plus pas moins le tact il suffira en
venant appuyer alors là ça vous crée
réellement un bouton physique donc là
vous avez vraiment la sensation du
bouton sur le doigt ce qui peut être pas
mal aussi mais ce qui aussi un peu con
c'est que on rajoute un système à
coulisse donc lui on va rajouter de côté
un peu mécanique et plus on va risquer
d'avoir un produit ou si vous avez une
connerie une cochonnerie bêtise une
grains de poussière en grain de sable
qui se met dedans et ben c'est ce qu'ont
fait un petit peu moins aimé je me dis
que si la voyait j'ai un petit grain de
sable qui passe et que je pousse la
caisse qui me dit que je vais pas venir
le glisser à l'intérieur c'est le truc
que je trouve un peu plus limitant à
côté de ça c'est assez marrant nous ont
bien un petit bouton rouge pour
seulement quand ils sont ouverts très
honnêtement on le voit quand ils sont
ouverts qu'à regarder ses affiches et on
le voit alors ces petites rigueur ils
sont intéressants pour le jeu parce que
lorsque vous allez jouer ça vous fait
des boutons supplémentaires si vous avez
l'habitude de jouer sera soit 9 vous
savez que vous avez vos boutons et s'il
a envoyé pour accélérer et là pour
tourner alors ce que j'ai fait moi à
regarder c'est que je viens ici là dans
mon mode là est juste là j'ai un petit
mode avec mes boutons gâchette et en
fait je suis venu les paramétrer c'est à
dire que celui là là c'est celui-là est
celui-là c'est celui là je les ai
positionner au bon endroit ce qui fait
que lorsque j'appuie la garder ben
j'accélère grâce que j'appuie là je
freine ou alors je fais mes petits sauts
de cabri alors je vais quand même faire
gaffe et après pour la direction par
contre sa mode pouces avec mon doigt ça
me donne une expérience de jeu qui est
quand même vachement bien et ça je
trouve ça super cool et j'adore donc là
je peux sauter tous les côtés il y aller
comme un gant et c'est marrant ce que ça
évite de tenir le smartphone comme ça
voyez aussi alors je peux tenir comme ça
et garder mais doit appuyer mais ça me
permet d'avoir d'autres positions et qui
pour le coup est assez intéressant voyez
comme ça je peux bien jouer et ça marche
donc en terme d'expérience d'immersion
c'est vachement bien alors là vous
l'avez sur asphalte 9 il ya deux boutons
- très clairement donc c'est facile sur
un peu glissé un peu plus limitatif par
exemple parce que comme sur un peuple 12
heures plusieurs boutons j'aime venir
paramétrer la course le seul fait de
s'allonger la direction est ici je suis
un peu plus limité donc c'est pas la
meilleure expérience là dessus au niveau
du gaming ça apporte un truc en plus je
pense que si vous allez sur un iphone et
que vous prenez des accessoires ça va
vous coûter très cher un très
honnêtement mais vous en ferez davantage
vous irait beaucoup plus loin pour jouer
sur un smartphone ici ça vient juste
rajouter deux petits boutons bon voilà
après à vous de me dire ce que vous en
pensez alors au delà du jeu ses boutons
ils sont intéressants parce qu'on peut
venir les utiliser pour faire autre
chose rare exemple le bouton o sur le
dessus l'aja puis deux fois samedi en
appareils photos j'appuie sur le bouton
la somme mais en côte et vidéo je laisse
appuyer là ça m'allume le flash voyez
cela s'appuyer ça ne le supprime donc
l'âge et de la puis longé de l'appui
kouriles a gémi le mode s'il en vibreur
en fait face à ces lâches fuyant
silencieux désactivé et là hop là je
suis en mode vibreur donc c'est les
petits raccourcis que je peux venir
personnalisé donc ça c'est cool je
trouve que là où l'expérience est pas
d'accès que je sais plus comment venir
les paramécies truc là parce que autant
on tourne sur me why 13 mio est restée
cependant que j'aime bien je lui en ai
déjà parlé outre ans je trouve que ici
et là je vois pas je trouve pas où c'est
donc là j'ai tous mes paramètres 2013 à
propos de l'appareil les mises à jour de
sécurité donc la mecque intime et qu'on
peut d'ailleurs il est double sim 5g ça
c'est intéressant il ya du wifi si eux
aussi donc si vous voulez quelque chose
qui va très bien en termes de
connectivité là-dessus liesse qui fonda
les dernières tectoniques ça ira mais
pour le reste voyez je trouve pas alors
c'est pas de l'écran ce n'est pas de ça
c'est pas de l'écran d'accueil c'est pas
du thème je le verrai vraiment moi dans
les paramètres supplémentaires mais dans
les paramètres supplémentaires je trouve
rien voilà je trouve que pour moi il ya
un truc qui est pas simple là dedans
capteur d'empreintes digitales double
pression c'est pas celui là puis en
arrière c'est l'arrière du smartphone
pour moi voyez il ya un truc c'est pas
évident et je trouve que là dessus il
faudrait bosser sur l'interface ou mieux
expliquer qu'on comprenne réellement de
quoi il s'agit comme un fou pour faire
ça alors je les fais pour la première
fois en revenant sur l'appareil photo et
en appuyant alassane a proposé de la
signer c'est facile mais maintenant pour
le modifier je suis incapable de vous
dire comment les modifier et j'ai pas
envie de passer des heures dans les
paramètres pour trouver comment le faire
donc là je trouve qu'ils aient un truc
un peu loupé qui est un peu dommage
maintenant un truc intéressant de ce
smartphone c'est quand même qu'ici ils
nous ont mis ce qui marche de mieux ben
oui on peut faire du gaming il faut de
la performance on a le stand dragon 8
jane 1 on va retrouver de la ram répéter
dire simple ça va très bien on est lui
ai fait trois points au niveau du
stockage thérapie en lecture en écriture
je vous ai dit on à ce qui va bien en
termes de connectivité wifi 6e 5 g on a
un autre qui est super intéressant et
qui sont vous livrer mon mac faisant ok
on a une batterie 4000 200 millions
perverses et pas une batterie de 5
millions terreur à côté de ça on a quand
même un processeur qui gère très bien
l'autonomie donc ça ça ira mais comme
vous avez des paramètres de jeu regardez
je vais vous montrer une fois de plus
lors les paramètres de jeu c'est pareil
il faudra ici je parle dans mon game
turbo où je vais avoir mes différents
jeux d'ailleurs il me parmi 6 g public
est là et là je peux avoir à prévoyez
game turbo raccourci j'ai pas un truc
assez intéressant qui nous ont vomi ici
démarrage rapide au kenya gnac la
gâchette un mode performance pour
optimiser ou qui est exceptionnel
mémoire et ensuite je veux avoir des
paramètres supplémentaires qui vont
dédié pour les jeux par exemple pour les
jeux je peux me dire
l'un des jeux m sur 1 pen j je peux bien
les gestes vont être en mode pro
personnalisés hop là ok je peux dire
vraiment ce que je vis au niveau de la
sensibilité bon je vais rester en
classique samira la zone tactile je peux
bien la réduire en bas lui pour que ce
soit pas puisse pas me poser problème où
j'ai dit il faut ce jeune de toucher oui
je m soit plus grands spas plus petit
soit carrément aucun et ensuite là j'ai
un truc qui est intéressant c'est là les
visuels je peux venir pousser le
contraste en fait voyez ça je la sens
original tel qu'il est là soit je peux
carrément cadets ce parce que vous
verrez bien différent s'il pourtant
garder une vraie différence si je le
mets en extrême gagner comme ça ressort
là donc là je ne sais pas mal un truc
qui marche bien je peux venir le faire
avec elle mais différents jeux donc là
ils ont vraiment bien bossé il ya un
truc qui est assez intéressant dans ce
truc là maintenant et je vous le dis une
fois de plus il faut que je revienne un
peu la barre des 6 me remets un jeu je
passe par là je vais dans mes paramètres
je les prends je vais sur le côté comme
ça voilà regardez là j'ai mon mode sur
un mode performance je peux venir
changer est passé en mode équilibré si
je veux y aller doucement au niveau de
la performance pour pas venir trop taper
dans ma batterie parce que plus je vais
y aller plus je vais consommer plus
smartphones va aussi chauffer au dos
même si on a un refroidissement
totalement optimisé ça finit par
chauffer quand même derrière donc vous
venez vous mettre en équilibre et si
vous avez vraiment un jeu gourmand venez
poussant les performances passées
derrière et si vous avez la performance
n'est pas de problème après vous avez
pris une petite option qu'on retrouve
vraiment un minuteur pour chronométrer
ces séances on peut diffuser on peut
castet on peut capturer l'écran enfin
bref en tout cas très très classique au
niveau des smartphones de gaming et je
vous disais tout à l'heure 4700
milliampères heures de batterie ok ça
marche mais si vous avez peur de
commencer à manquer et bien ils nous ont
fait un truc qui est intéressant nous
ont dit blake de charges qu'ils ont mis
pour la première fois à côté de chez
shiomi dans le chiot me sens le 11 t
procès ce bloc de charge 120 watts alors
ce beauf de charge 120 watts qu'il est
intéressant parce que ça vous permet de
recharger de 2 à 100% en 17 minutes
c'est extrêmement rapide alors attention
vous avez une charge 120 watts au début
tout tutelle diminue vous allez tomber
problement à 80 watts à 65 watts pour
venir vraiment éviter de flinguer votre
batterie donc le truc qui est plutôt pas
mal ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est
le connecteur qui est un peu différent
voyez on est effectivement sur de l'usbc
mais il vous l'ont mis comme ça comme ça
vous passez par tous et puis surtout hop
là il est un peu plus dure à a rentré un
peu plus dur à retirer également c'est
parce qu'il est neuf aussi ça peut aussi
expliquer ça que je trouve que c'est pas
mal d'avoir un truc comme ça très
honnêtement vous me sens un peu un peu
de gueule donc why not pourquoi pas le
truc qui est intéressant c'est que vous
avez aussi quelque chose qui fait au
niveau de la protection de votre
batterie si par exemple vous décider le
brochet le soir et lui et ses proches et
toute la nuit ce qui n'est pas une bonne
idée vous le branchez vous vous être
rechargé en un quart d'heure et bien ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'en fait il ya
une protection si par exemple vous
mettez un réveil le matin 7h vous le
branchez le soir il va recharger jusqu'à
80% et il va couper il va mettre la
pause et qu'est ce qui va faire ce qui
va se dire ok pour recharger les 20% qui
brest il faut quoi allez on sait qu'il
planait 20% il met plus de temps il lui
faut peut-être j'en sais rien moi cinq
minutes eh bien on va dire qu à 6h55 qui
va lancer la charge pour les cinq
dernières minutes et hop à cette heure
vos smartphones est chargé à 100% que ce
qui va venir préserver la batterie de
votre smartphone alors après on a déjà
parlé de ça dans une précédente vidéo ce
qui est évident c'est ce qu'il faut
faire vous laisser charger entre 20 80 %
vous ne changez pas au dessus comme vous
avez une recherche très rapide où robben
smartphone voulu charger en dix minutes
donc vous êtes tranquille là dessus il
ya pas de souci donc ça c'est plutôt
intéressant alors il ya un autre truc
que nous dit ici au causse et qu'on a
quatre haut parleurs ou qu'il ya des
smartphones sur lesquels ça marchera
bien c'est notamment ce qu'on retrouve
du côté du chiot midouze pas de souci
là-dessus bien c'est de vous ce proche
croit on a tellement que je flippe a
plus à voir bon alors ça le truc c'est
qu'effectivement on a quand même de la
puissance pour venir jouer à des jeux ou
des du son très facilement gardé un bon
c'est un peu
ça des honda haut parleurs qui est là
d'ailleurs ce que j'aime bien c'est
qu'ils ont fait une petite ouverture qui
est différente par rapport à ce qu'on
approche d'un smartphone donc ça doit
vraiment lui donner un livre un peu
différent et vous avez le deuxième c'est
là donc là c'est pareil le look est très
différent ça pas mal alors même si j'ai
pas plus d'infos sur convaincu mais au
niveau de nos hauts parleurs je pense
que je dois avoir 104 parleurs un haut
parleur grave un haut parleur aiguë par
côté pour venir séparer la fréquence
lorsque la voyez chez laffont
sature pas que ça reste assez assez
cohérent alors attention c'est pas
smartphones sur lequel on va voir
beaucoup de grave on est sur un
smartphone de toute façon va pas
développer des mâles de grave mais pour
venir jouer à des jeux regarder des
films des séries ça ira alors après ce
que je vous recommande et bien c'est à
dire utiliser un petit casque sans fil
grâce au bluetooth 5.2 pour venir vous
préserver mais pour passer vos appels et
venir vous préserver des ondes en direct
comme ça contre votre tronche donc ça
c'est plutôt intéressant alors derniers
points dont je vous parlais qui est
super important quand on parle d'un
smartphone gaming et bien c'est le fait
qu'on a un écran amoled donc ça c'est
plutôt pas mal on un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 air ça c'est un
très grand classique la dalle est très
belle elle ne trouve vraiment très très
belle cette dalle plutôt bien bien
calibré voulait venir ici hop là dans
les paramètres de l'écran alors grand
classique un thème sombre thème clair la
luminosité hop je trouve assez lumineux
très honnêtement là par défaut intense
il tire un peu sur le bleu si vous
voulez bien réchauffé poignet se le
mettre sur couleur originale je le
trouve pas mal ça me réchauffe et très
légèrement envoyés et c'est plutôt
plutôt pas mal fichu comme ça après taux
d'actualisation vous le laissez par
défaut comme ça il va se faire de façon
totalement optimisé jusqu'à 120 hertz
nom pouvait venir le faire vous
directement poussé à la main soit 60
soit 120 heures je voulais conseille de
laisser en recommandé toujours dans
l'idée du gaming vous avez un taux
d'échantillonnage tactile de 480 hertz
dalle de 6,67 pouces qui est assez
grande pas forcément s'en doutera c'est
un grand smartphone alors les bords ça
me dérange pas le point sombre on s'y
habitue assez à ses looks l'ain non je
trouve pas mal alors après ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'effectivement il un
look un peu à part même au niveau du
flash led la regardez là ça vous fait un
petit éclair vous avez également ici de
l'infrarouge à ces trucs vraiment de
chez home is est une des rares marques
qui vous garde de l'infrarouge pour
utiliser votre smartphone comme une
télécommande du nfc pour le paiement
dématérialisé vous avez un corning
gorilla glass electus qui veuille bien
protégé donc là c'est plutôt pas mal
aussi le capteur d'empreintes qui situe
au niveau du bouton vous posez votre
doigt ça des verrous très rapidement et
puis en photo vous avez une config qui a
si simple vous avez un capteur principal
de 64 mégapixels vous avez un ultra
grand-angle de 8 mégapixels et vous avez
une caméra back round 2 mégapixels l
avance une caméra de cette fille de 2
mégapixels alors comme on est sur un
smartphone vraiment dit igaming je vais
pas aller gratter du côté de la photo
s'est pas réellement ce qui va venir
m'intéressait ici parce que et ç'a
toujours été le cas un chapeau qu on a
surtout des smartphones qui sont
optimisés du côté de la performance pour
venir faire plein de choses mais pas
nécessairement du côté photo donc ce
smartphone que vous dire il est un peu
cher on s'en doutera 600 euros et 700
euros c'est pas forcément le smartphone
qui va être pour toutes les bourses je
le trouve pas mal parce que si vous
voulez il ya un truc qui est intéressant
café poko ici c'est le fait de se dire
on va venir se mettre au niveau d'autres
smartphones de gaming il coûte plus cher
pour moi une des références et le rock
fun de asus qui a plein d'options si
vous prenez les manettes vous prenez la
compet ça peut coûter cher en terme
d'expérience pour jouer sur un
smartphone c'est vraiment extraordinaire
là ça marche super bien je sais pas si
effectivement le fait d'avoir mis ses
petits boutons là c'est vraiment la
vraie bonne idée parce que même si je
peux avoir des raccourcis pour passer à
d'un mode à l'autre eh bien il faut que
je vienne le pousser donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut laisser en permanence ouvert
je suis pas extrêmement convaincu je
trouve ça marrant mais une fois de plus
j'ai peur qu'ils aient des trucs qui
viennent se mettre là dedans et que ça
vous là bim qui à force votre bouton
soit ça ce blog soit ça sort plus que ça
devienne un peu casser l'idée du truc
quoi ce qui est sûr ici c'est que on a
de la performance qui le maîtrise c'est
plutôt une jolie configuration donc si
vous voulez un bon smartphone de gaming
et que vous aimez l'idée d'avoir ces
petits boutons là pourquoi pas ça reste
très gadget si on veut vraiment ou
qu'intéressant niveau du gaming et qu'on
a un peu d'argent il faut aller sur le
rock food d'asus avec des accessoires ça
coûte plus cher mais la laisse penser
beaucoup plus complète pour que
progressent pour qu'on va plus loin pour
qu étoffe sa gamme avec ce f4 j'étais
intéressante parce que vous en pensez
vous est ce que c'est un produit qui
peut vous tentez vite les mois
d'ailleurs en en bas en commentaires
plutôt bien je trouve ce cher je sais
pas si j'ai 700 euros en baisse sur vos
smartphones de gaming je suis pas sûr
d'aller là dessus que je pense vous une
fois de plus j'irai voir sur un
smartphone
peut-être du côté de chez asus sur un
roc phone du dernière génération qui
même si on n'a pas le dernier c'est un
dragon restera très actuel pour jouer un
peu de gigaset de souci là-dessus parce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
vous donne rendez vous très vite et on
continue à parler bien évidemment de
teck parler de beaucoup de plein
d'autres choses et ça c'est cool plus
embrassades et obtient
[Musique]